and you know i know you love your fans
so much because recently even i heard
that you helped some families with some
funeral expenses um from the loss of
their loved ones and they were fans of
yours and i know you didn't do that for
recognition but it must have made you
feel good that you can help them out and
that is so keeping in keeping with your
character how did that make you feel
yeah you know um i think back to what
charles kelly said on stage tonight um
he said you know if you're in this
business it's your responsibility to
give back to you know your community and
to the fans and um that's something that
that i truly believe you know i've been
blessed um you know beyond measure uh
and getting to do something that i love
every day you know i'm so lucky to do
that
and it would just feel wrong to not
you know at every chance you have to
help somebody else uh in a tough
situation um to do that and and
obviously it felt great you know it's
it's something that um
you know it's just so tragic and
unfortunate um you know to know that
that those three boys
you know that their last show was seeing
me that night is something that i never
would have imagined and something that i
can't even imagine how difficult it is
on their family and
you know money is the last thing that
somebody should have to worry about at a
time like that obviously we just had
um all the horrific flooding here
in middle tennessee that's real close to
where i live i just had some flooding
back in my hometown of asheville so
working on some stuff to uh to try to
get some relief to those folks you know
in their time of need um and that's
something that i enjoy man i enjoy
giving back you know
this thing's never been about me it's
always been about the fans because
without them there is no me so yes that
is something that that makes me feel
great something that i'm blessed to do
and something that i will continue to do
as long as i can
so you also have a brand new song
dropping tomorrow so sonya what can you
tell us about that yeah you know i wrote
that song in a in a parking lot in
orange beach alabama a couple years ago
me and some friends that got a lead that
the sec was looking for a song uh to
kind of go
uh you know hand in hand with football
season and
we wrote this this great song called
south on you and um
you know it didn't work out at that time
you know uh but i i believe that you
know everything happens for a reason and
i ended up making a friend and marty
smith who who works at espn and sending
it to him a year or so later and he was
able to kind of run it up the flagpole
at espn and
the sec picked it up this year so it's
kind of coming out in conjunction with
football season
it's a song that we wrote you know with
with football in the south in mind so uh
it's a fun song
uh super upbeat uh kind of a as much of
a headbanger i guess as you're gonna get
out of me so i'm really looking forward
to seeing what people think about it
it's my first new song in a while so i'm
a little nervous and really excited